[موسيقى]
دخان يتصاعد فوق جنوب غزة يطارد
من
مسافة، مقطع فيديو مرعب عن قرب
حصلت عليه شبكة سي إن إن يظهر رصيفًا
مغطى بالدماء
وجثث رجال ونساء وأطفال، ما لا يقل عن 20
قتيلاً من غارة جوية إسرائيلية أخرى
هذه المرة بالقرب من مستشفى تابع
لوزارة الصحة التي تسيطر عليها حماس  تقول CNN إنها
غير قادرة على التحقق بشكل مستقل من
عدد القتلى المذهل الذي يبلغ حوالي 20 ألفًا،
وهرع الجرحى إلى
مستشفى الأمل، وهو واحد من عدد قليل من الأطباء الذين ما زالوا
يعملون في ساحة انتظار السيارات، وسط فوضى عارمة، حيث يتدافع الأطباء والممرضات
بالفعل
لإنقاذ الأرواح،
فريق دولي من الجراحين.  القدرة على الوصول إلى
غرف الطوارئ على
أطباء دعم الحياة يحذرون من أن الإمدادات
تنخفض بشكل خطير، مما يحد بشدة من
علاج مرضى الصدمات،
بعضهم يموت أثناء انتظار الرعاية العاجلة. عدد
الضحايا المدنيين يتزايد بسرعة أكثر
من 55000 جريح منذ 7 أكتوبر، حسبما
تقول وزارة الصحة التابعة لحماس داخل
خيمة طبية مزدحمة  في جباليا، الهلال
الأحمر الفلسطيني يعالج المسعفون
موجة عارمة من
المرضى، والنساء والأطفال، والعديد من
الإصابات المروعة، وكومة
أكياس الجثث التي تتزايد
كل ساعة، وفي بعض الأحيان يبدو أن عدد القتلى
يفوق عدد السفن البحرية الحية التي تمشط
الساحل بينما تحلق طائرات بدون طيار في سماء المنطقة
لتوثيق الانفجار المدمر.
بعد الانفجار، استهدف جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي
الأنفاق التي يستخدمها مقاتلو حماس، وقصف
البنية التحتية العسكرية والمدنية، ولم يُظهر الهجوم الإسرائيلي في
غزة أي علامات على تخفيف
هدف إسرائيل المتمثل في القضاء على قادة حماس، ويبدو أن مقطع
فيديو تم تحريره يتم تداوله على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
يُظهر رجالًا فلسطينيين
واثنين على الأقل  أطفال محتجزون
جردتهم قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية من ملابسهم في
ملعب بشمال
غزة، القتال شرس،
ومن المتوقع أن يتحول الهجوم إلى
حملة متنقلة أبطأ كثافة قريبًا،
تقول إسرائيل إن السؤال الذي يؤرق
القادة الإسرائيليين هو ما إذا كان التغيير في
الاستراتيجية فعالاً، وهل سيعمل على تحييد
جيش حماس؟  قصف مدفعي إسرائيلي
مدرسة تابعة للأمم المتحدة في وسط غزة مما أدى إلى حدوث
ثقوب في الجدران ودماء على
الأرضيات بجوار فرشات نوم
العائلات النازحة في هذه المدرسة في
رفح، حيث تتجمع بعض هذه العائلات في
الفصول الدراسية لتتخلص من القليل من الطعام
والماء الذي لديهم  تنخفض
بعد 10 أسابيع طويلة من
الحرب، يقول رئيس الوزراء الفلسطيني إن
إسرائيل تجوع الناس حتى
الموت [موسيقى] درس هذا المعلم
إلهاء مرحب به للأطفال المحاطين
بالمعاناة والموت الذين يحاولون العثور على بعض
مظاهر الحياة الطبيعية ويل ريبلي
سي إن إن تل